we can speak now to conservative MP and
the father at the house can flapper who
joins us now live from his constituency
thank you very much for being on the
program this morning now you first
arrived in the House of Commons in 1970
so you witnessed the formation of the
SDP
so I'm very interested to know your
thoughts and whether you think the
independent group represents a real
realignment in British politics or if
it's more likely to just be a flash in
the pan
like most other things is too soon to
say I think it's essentially it's the
people's vote movement that unites the
labour and conservative MPs as well that
have joined it they obviously want to
produce a moderating force they quite
rightly perceived that the two major
parties are currently in chaos but it's
far too soon to see how it's going to
develop everything really depends if
either see when penning on Tom whether
either of the two major parties the
Conservatives or the Labour Party can
put themselves back together again and
make themselves resemble the broad part
is they were before that gave the
country a sensible choice of government
which both are in a shambles at the
moment so I'm hoping this week some key
votes and we might begin to see some
return to order in the chaos at the
moment the House of Commons and as hit
the party political system it's
interesting to hear you talk about the
group that they want to see a second
referendum that politics in a minute is
in chaos and they want to provide a
moderating force I mean a you at all
tempted by them I'm a lifelong
conservative I mean I am I think I you
would agree I was part of the
conservative establishment for the first
60 years of my membership that my views
have been the mainstream views of the
Conservative Party so I I'm not I don't
think i'll leave the Conservative Party
because my principles which I hold you
very firmly there are those which I
think the Conservative Party should
represent free markets for the social
conscience in
nationalism a rules-based international
order and britain playing a proper role
in the world I won't go on about my
principles but that's what the
Conservative Party should stand on its
this referendum and it's the word Europe
let us call such chaos and I don't think
we'll be clear until we've eventually
come out of this brexit crisis which I
actually think is a few years away we
haven't started the serious negotiations
yet years to go this then and
interesting that you're talking there
about the principles that our
conservative party should stand on do
you agree with some of the analysis of
MPs like Heidi Allen for example who was
saying the Conservative Party has
shifted to the right and is effectively
being dominated by MPs who were members
of the European research group I'm sorry
to keep saying it's too soon to say
I think we've never had an organized
right-wing party within a party the
European research group is obviously
determined to make the party a quite
different party and turn off to the
right not just on Rexy belong quite a
lot of other things and they've been
concentrating on trying to get rid of
Teresa may for that purpose they seem to
be trying again with demands that she
steps down after the local government
elections for some reason they organized
a coup Jacob Riis Mowgli their coup if I
might say so rather incompetent Lee
which she survived a month or two ago
and I hope they're not going to start
all that again but whilst we have this
party with its own leader Jacob its own
Chief Whip and all its pressures to try
to undermine the government and bounce
it into hardline views I was it there's
a bit of a threat but yeah we've always
but as long as I've been to the party
it's been a broad church we had some
very right-wing members when I first
joined it of whom I was not one who
trying to undermine my great hero him
McLeod who they said was giving the
Empire
we had a lot of trouble with Enoch
Powell I personally still hope believe
that a conservative party is quite
capable of bringing yourself back
together again
or many things we don't have the deep
ideological divide which has always been
a bigger problem for the Labour Party
between hardline ultra socialists and
Social Democrats which is caused
permanent fights as long as that
movement has existed but they usually
think oh and we'll see how both parties
get on you speak there about a party
within a party I mean that sounds like
it in a way you're hinting towards kind
of almost entry and certainly in the
reservation letter from the three former
Conservative MPs they spoke about a
purple momentum subsuming the
Conservative Party I mean we've seen a
lot of the analysis around momentum and
a Labour Party do you think we're seeing
a similar thing with the Conservative
Party well Aaron banks leave UK are
quite open in saying that's what they're
doing one of their junior ministers
Richard Harrington finds that the man
who stood for you Kip against him of the
last election has joined his
constituency Association together with
quite a few other former you keep
members I don't think it's happening
everywhere but Aaron banks I think is
quite openly organizing them helping
back just such a movement again
political parties become weaker nowadays
particularly the Conservative Party
which doesn't have a big enough
voluntary membership anymore we do have
to guard against the danger which the
Labour Party has suffered from all of an
unrepresentative group in their case
momentum sweeping in and taking over all
the institutions of the party that would
change the party fundamentally anything
that made the Conservative Party
resemble hardline right-wing European
research group would actually produce a
new and different party for the one that
I've always belonged to if you were 29
now the age when you first and joined
the House comments would you still
the concept a party that's a very good
question that I'm not sure I would want
to because I am a right-of-center
person naturally by the time I was 29 my
views were very settled and we're a very
very liberal but I move important things
exactly the same as they are now they
were my adult firmly formed views if I
joined I would there I would be in the
belief that I was great see they
conservative party returned to common
sense and returned to some sensible
principles I would if I mean obviously I
would be someone who will be not going
around presenting myself as a member of
that hard right and now three cabinet
ministers concerned about No Deal this
week said that they would vote for an
extension to article 50 rather than see
the UK leave the EU without a deal do
you think that MP is going to vote to
take no deal off the table this week I
hope so over well there's one thing that
clearly is a majority for the House of
Commons on a cross body basis is
delaying leaving and I think it's
perfectly clear we're in no position to
leave on the 29th of March I have no
idea why some people are including the
Prime Minister keep repeating that date
as though it has some significant or
sacrosanct quality it's a totally
arbitrary date it happens to be two
years after the Prime Minister for
reasons I don't quite understand first
announced in rented the revoking of
article 50 I think because as she was
already hanging stirrings of discontent
from her right-wingers and she wanted to
cheer them up
but the idea that the 29th of March is
some sacrosanct date and that the 30th
of March would be an impossible betrayal
for example is one of the daft arguments
that take place if you look at the chaos
the shambles
the fact that European neighbors the
other governments are almost giving up
because they can't work out what on
earth the new arrangements are that the
British think they want it is obvious
that we all need more time you can't
just take a crazy gamble on the 29th of
March cancel every legal trading
regulatory arrangement we have not only
with Europe but we have send the other
countries across the world and see what
happens the next day so of course I
should be backing this amendment I hope
it's going to be voted on on Wednesday
and I expect the the government will
sort of start trying to find some way of
putting it off because they seem to
think they'll get on better if they try
and terrifying the House of Commons by
giving them all the key votes with about
a week to go I think just to get some
calm some order some basis for proper
governance some common sense back into
this debate what's the public a
demanding I think obvious thing to do is
to delay it we're not ready with no
consensus of what we actually want our
future role in the world to be so as we
gather I quite vehemently will be voting
for it just as I voted for him Yvette
Cooper's Nick bowls amendment fortnight
ago which didn't lose by too much it was
defeated then actually that one was
defeated by hardline koban Easter brexit
ears in the Labour Party clearly while
on labour back benches front benches who
wouldn't vote for it somebody who work
on those I hope more conservative
backbench MPs will pluck up courage
together with these ministers quite a
lot of Ministers not just a three
cabinet
members it's not disloyal it's not
faintly destructive it is necessary to
give the British more time so we can
actually have a grown-up sensible
political debate because we made our
minds up there's been indicative votes
or something in the House of Commons to
show what is the chosen course we're
actually proposing to follow what I
think anyone could be in any doubts
about how you're likely to vote when it
comes to an extension to article 50 I'm
interested to hear your thoughts on
another story though
and that about Shamima Begum the girl
from Bethnal Green who left the UK to
join Islamic state the Home Secretary
has decided to remove her British
citizenship and I just wonder if you
think that was the right call
and how the UK should respond to her
case I spent my entire life trying not
to rebell Amal the one subject to once
but I strongly disapprove of the
decision to take citizenship away from
this unpleasant woman the big overall
picture which in modern politics nobody
ever looks at him it's good governance
were meant to be concerned about is
there our hundreds of Western European
jihadists or in Syria in camps and
they're some of the much more dangerous
people this woman though she's bad
enough and the obvious thing is that
we've got to follow international law
those who are citizens of Western
Western countries who come from those
countries have got to be taken back by
those countries now those countries must
deal with them severely if necessary
certainly for any crimes they've
committed and I think those countries
intelligence services have got to face
the challenge of looking after them but
with you the rules always be you take
back your own citizens it's the rule
United Kingdom insists on when we send
foreign criminals back to their states
and say international law says you got
to take back this wicked person and
you must deal with him he can't keep
living here now this particular woman is
obviously Bangladesh there obviously yes
she's obviously not Bangladeshi she's
obviously British and it's our duty to
take her back and make sure she doesn't
cause any harm and you can't start
saying to Bangladesh she's got
Bangladesh parents so you've got to take
her and she's never been there in her
life and the rules being interpreted in
a crazy way I mean they're probably
being looked at at the moment by large
numbers of British citizens who have
Irish grandparents and a quite a lot of
them were taking out Irish passports I'm
told to make sure they can have proper
movement about the rest of the EU once
the British have left you can't say to
somebody who's lived here all their life
it's a British citizen as British as you
me oh you have an Irish grandparent so
if you commit a serious criminal offence
we're going to take your citizenship
away from you and tell the Irish they've
got to take you back that's all nonsense
you know the vast numbers of people have
at least one foreign parent or foreign
grandparent and it is the populism yes
to take away the citizenship there you
go in the proper way of dealing with it
it's the rule of law and proper
punishment proper security steps if
that's what you want okay Kent Clark
thank you very much for being on the
program this morning